c'est un commerce où les agriculteurs
sont les vendeurs de leur production ce
magasin de vente directe située à loches
inaugure sa première journée d'ouverture
on fait tous de la vente directe au sein
de nos exploitations il ya deux mois
nous avons nos clients et le principe
était de regrouper l'ensemble des
exploitations sur un site aussi pour
faciliter
l'accès de nos produits à la clientèle
en viande fruits et légumes produits
laitiers pain de quoi faire le plein
pour une semaine de course beaucoup de
le choix sont venus tester ce nouveau
concept certains par curiosité d'autres
en soutien aux producteurs comme cet
ancien agriculteur il serait très bien
que nos grands magasins une faune des
siennes avec les prix
chacun défendre comme il peut alors ça
c'est une défense en regard des
producteurs pour essayer de gagner leur
croûte et pour faire face à la
concurrence de l'hypermarché d'en face
ici l'argument choc c'est la qualité et
la traçabilité des marchandises qui est
produit dans un rayon de 30 km on va
voir si la violer et bonnes et moins
cher que dans les supermarchés et si
c'est la vraie bien c'est une marche
assez bien mais on sait pas distinguer
les trois quarts du temps quant aux
agriculteurs de ses magasins il trouve
ici notre manière d'écouler leurs
marchandises l'intérêt de vendre et s'il
n'y a pas d'intermédiaire
on reste
propriétaire de nos produits donc de la
ferme au panier de la ménagère et et
puis pouvoir parler aussi de mode
produit parce que
les mettre en rayon il ya un libre
service par exemple c'est très bien mais
enfin nous à la ferme on aime bien
parler de ce qu'on fait voilà reste pour
les dix producteurs de ce commerce à
fidéliser leur clientèle sur un rapport
qualité prix au plus juste